-Welcome, welcome back.
We have so much to talk about.
How's the family, by the way,
first of all?
-Family, amazing.
My three daughters thriving.
We came back
from a summer in Spain.
-Yeah, you Zoomed
with me from Spain.
Thank you for doing that,
by the way.
-Yep.
-And I just got to see
how fun you are
with the whole fam.
Here they are, actually.
I have a picture of you
and the family.
Oh, this is --
your daughter's graduated?
-Yep.
-Yeah, look at that.
Come on.
-Ines, Carlota, Lucia.
I gave the speech on her
graduation -- on my youngest.
-Oh, really?
At the school?
-And I was so super-nervous,
because my daughter kind of
introduced me to everybody.
And she goes into the speech,
and she says, "Well, my dad,
you may think, is a good daddy,
but he never let us order food
from the kids' menu
in the restaurant."
[ Laughter ]
Like, really?
This was the nicest thing
you could say about me?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, anyway, daughters --
I love my daughters.
-Yeah, of course, yeah.
I want to talk about
World Central Kitchen,
because we've done --
we were together in Puerto Rico.
And sadly, Puerto Rico got hit
with another Hurricane now.
It is rough.
But, I --
What you've done
for so many people,
I mean, I think the first one,
maybe, was that Bahamas
or something?
-Well, Bahamas was a big one.
We did over 3 million meals
with 14 islands,
but we began really in Haiti
in 2010 after the earthquake.
And this was very simple.
It's not me.
It's the people.
Yes, I go, and I tell
everybody, "Let's cook!
Let's feed anybody that needs --
needs our help."
And let me tell you
what happens.
Everybody wants
to join this simple idea.
Big problems, actually,
they have very simple solutions.
Cooks, what do we do?
We start cooking,
and we start feeding.
You see, we can do it
when we all come together.
That's what we've been doing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's amazing what you're doing.
We were together --
We were together in Puerto Rico,
and we were eating pastelitos.
-You show up and spend there
many days doing a show,
showing the beautiful people
of Puerto Rico
coming back, coming together.
That you took the step
to leave your studio,
show up in Puerto Rico,
and give love and hope
and show all America
and all the world
how amazing these people are,
that was amazing.
So, thank you for doing that.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was just --
obviously, you feel it.
You feel it with the people
when you see everyone
and you get there.
And Puerto Rico is so beautiful.
Go visit.
Tourism is such a part
of their economy,
so please go support
Puerto Rico.
But I remember, I ate --
I took a bite of the --
and you said,
"Jimmy, you're eating it wrong."
And I go, "What do you mean?"
You go, "When you eat food
this good,
you have to close your eyes."
[ Laughter ]
-I mean,
he was not closing his eyes.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
-He's just eating it
with his open eyes.
-"His open eyes"?
Yeah.
-He look like a shark.
I mean, I like sharks.
Sharks are good people,
believe me.
But, I mean --
-That's ridiculous.
-But he's there, he's eating,
and the woman are looking like,
"What's happening there?"
"I don't know."
I said, "Jimmy,
can you show some emotion?"
I mean --
-[ Laughs ] Come on.
-Show me -- "Mmm!"
You did great in the second try.
-Look at you now.
[ Light laughter ]
I feel like you're, like,
an actor now.
'Cause now I look at you --
'cause you're in a cartoon,
and now you're a big actor now.
So it's gone to your head.
Look at your acting gear.
You're so --
Yes, it's -- you're changing.
-It's not going to my head!
They couldn't find anybody else
with an accent, and they --
[ Laughter ]
And they --
And they picked me.
-It's called "Firebuds,"
and here you are --
you're Chef Al in "Firebuds."
And I thought that was
really cool to do,
just for all the kids out there.
-I'm loving it.
It was great.
Nobody could understand my
English, so that's fine.
That's why they called me.
But, listen,
I hope I'll do more.
-How -- How are you doing that?
You're giving all of your time.
You're flying --
You're in Ukraine,
you're doing all the stuff,
and you're opening restaurants,
as well.
-Well --
-You opened one
here in New York.
-At the new Ritz-Carlton hotel,
in the NoMad,
I opened a restaurant
called Zaytinya, which is Greek.
I opened a bar in the rooftop,
has one of the best rooftops
in the history of New York.
-You have another one in L.A.,
but how do you manage your time?
Do you know
where you are right now?
-Well, I mean...
-Do you know where --
Take a guess --
Take a guess where you are.
-I mean, Jimmy --
Jimmy Fallon show, New York.
-Yes! You're right!
You nailed it.
You nailed it, New York.
[ Applause ]
-But, you know, right now,
obviously, you see what
has happened with Fiona.
Huge hurricane,
has affected multiple islands,
multiple countries.
I can be here with you now,
because the team we have
at World Central Kitchen
is beyond amazing.
Right now,
we are in Dominican Republic,
in Puerto Rico, in Bermuda.
Tuesday,
landed in Turks and Caicos.
They are in Alaska.
They just came from Jackson,
helping with water.
We're in Pakistan
and Afghanistan.
We reach 160 million meals alone
inside Ukraine.
I do what I do
because the people are amazing.
[ Applause ]
-Do you think --
It's awesome, what you're doing.
-But you know how we do it?
Are you hungry?
You need help?
You need food?
-Yeah.
-So, okay.
This was in your greenroom.
Here, food.
-Thank you so much.
-Carrots.
-Yes, thank you.
Did this inspire --
[ Laughter ]
If I don't do it,
he's gonna be upset.
-You have carrots.
You should eat vegetables.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He's learning.
♪♪
-Um, did -- did all of this
inspire your podcast,
"Longer Tables"?
-Yeah.
You didn't do any "Mmm."
[ Laughter ]
-The band was playing!
-Ah, okay, okay.
Yeah.
"Longer Tables"
is this very simple idea
that if we build longer tables,
not higher walls,
and we allow everybody
just to join the same table
and give the same opportunity
to everybody,
we can really build
a better world.
That's the idea of
longer tables,
where food is at the heart,
food is love, food is dignity.
People, you know, don't want our
pity, they want our respect.
Food is a great way
to give respect to people.
-Yeah, the longer the table,
the more people can talk.
[ Applause ]
Chef José Andrés.
For more information on how
to get involved
with the World Central Kitchen,
go to wck.org.
We'll be right back
with Ana Fabrega.
Stick around, everybody.